i got a little story to tell you have
you ever met a girl that you tried to
date
but a year to make gloves she wanted you
to wait
let me tell you a story in my situation
i was talking to this girl from the u.s
nation he dubbed himself the clown
prince
of hip-hop rapper biz marquis reached
stardom with his 1989
ode to the brokenhearted
you got what i need
but you
[Music]
just a friend reached platinum status
and was the biggest hit of bismarck he's
career
he died friday at the age of 57.
after hearing the song the new york
times called bismarck he
the father of bad singing but the rapper
explained
no one showed up at the studio to sing
that part of the song
so he did it himself
born marcel theo hall the harlem native
broke into music during the early days
of hip-hop as a beat boxer
a skill he later showed off to mass
audiences in the blockbuster
men in black too
he faced legal trouble in the 90s for
sampling a song without permission
the case had a precedent in the music
industry while he never scored a hit as
big as
just a friend the song no one wanted to
sing
is still on rolling stone's list of the
top 100
pop songs of all time don't ever do a
girl
always be one of my favorites always
always always good stuff we'll be right
back